[Music]
and not her news by Walter from bel-air
you saw rich Walter three people I have
been arrested for killing a woman in a
jealousy field murder plot
jealousy is dangerous three
[ __ ] killed [ __ ] I
know what happened there was a girl that
was dating a gangbanger and then that
girl was like you know what honey
these [ __ ] pissed me off and
that getting big I went to go kill these
[ __ ] that's what happened no
yeah fast you couldn't even entertain me
huh let's continue that's why I just
date online yeah so this story takes
place in Florida and it seems like
there's this woman here her name is
Ashna
35 years old I think it's spelled
backwards that's right finish Rashmi
Rashmi hey that's better
mm-hmm so she was upset that a man she
loved was in a relationship with another
woman and so she hired this man named
Alexis 35 years old and his girlfriend
his baby
Alexis the girlfriend named she don't do
named Alexis cuz it's a girl stripper
name I guess yeah he's pretty buff yeah
so she ended up hiring Alexis and his
girlfriend glorianne Marie
these names are interesting you could
only be a murderer with these names
Alexis and Gloria Marie yeah like 35
glory and Marie is 22 that's definitely
a woman's name like Alexis yeah unless
this dude is Russian and the S is silent
or something is he Oh Alexis don't well
I love them ramaa
so he's Espanola is confused anyway the
point is so they were told that this
woman worked at Ross and so they went to
Ross they were waiting for her to get
out of her job they ended up approaching
the wrong target but they didn't know
that at the time they followed the
target home then forced her into the
back of her car and then drove her to an
apartment in Orlando where they
eventually found they realized that they
had the wrong person but they decided to
cover anyway they already know too much
I only saw my face how did they kill her
they beat her and then they suffocated
her because of the garbage bags that I
made around do it quick what the hell
man I know she'd even deserve [ __ ] in
the first place now like that's the way
to me killer god damn so no question is
what would you won't have to have to
happen to you for you to kill somebody
oh yeah a start for me to kill someone
no for you to kill somebody
oh that's easy oh really uh-huh yeah
what is it
anything yep not anything like if it's
like some crazy-ass [ __ ] like I said got
like sexually assaulted by somebody oh
that prisons that how would you do it
those the question me I think for sure
consult you guys or maybe not you know
you sorry though you look out your the
taken you know about this meeting
you're the one with like the folk like
the blue princess what's going on here
what do you mean not me I got killed I
can't even give yourself a gun in your
own dream why you can tell you things
alright so first of all I don't tell you
guys to bring it back why I know kill I
killed you'll be too clumsy and [ __ ]
everything up and get us all arrested
you be the you'd kid up the wrong person
I got it for you that's my mom okay well
excuse me could you yeah
so yeah continue with the story
they ended up dumping her body and then
they abandoned her car there were some
cable workers I found her body so sad
he's trying to install some [ __ ]
Wi-Fi or something
not that part that's not that part sad
part is the fact they killed this woman
she was married I'm head of 14 year old
son oh no see this is how superheroes
are made now the fourteen-year-old son
is gonna grow up yep
and fight crime and he's inspired to be
a police officer or maybe become a
villain because he's like the world is a
[ __ ] up place he might only attack men
with female names yo yeah actually yeah
they were arrested really soon after the
body was found and they all three
confessed to the crime the jealous woman
that hired these fools to kill so she
okay
so she she's jealous but she didn't give
a good description apparently not like
she's the lady with the hair bun and
then they got on somebody that's in a
picture maybe someone looked really
close like if they try to kill like
Gilda tell or whatever right Leslie's
your name damn good Oh gallant got dog
dog but she want a woman though she'll
[ __ ] him up yeah then they kill me on
accident don't you ever [ __ ] compare
yourself to that beautiful woman
[Applause]
people think I'm delusional for always
watching my back but things like this
happen all the time and I'm at JK news
and every day it could be my last day
you know what that's true
cuz if you really believe that right
like you don't it okay well he's not
believe it - okay okay I'll just go back
but if you really believe that our guess
you do
you would probably a little bit more
like incognito and not wear like bright
color shirts or like cats all over your
shirt with dog sweaters
I'm not afraid of her I'm just cautious
after I bought groceries I'm like this
we're just two gallons of milk yep I'm
just I see you I see you got a paranoid
too every time I get in the back of
earth every time I get into my car I
always have to take in the backseat I do
want I know for a fact a hundred percent
if in fact I do have children they are
going to be [ __ ] made [ __ ]
because they're not gonna know when to
check certain things because they don't
have that fear you know what I mean cuz
I know we call it paranoia but I think
it's actually kind of smart you know
when you go up something else you check
okay something in the back of the car it
doesn't freak you out but it keeps your
senses up and I know a lot of these kids
they don't even got that [ __ ] this
alright what do you want to do Jimmy
before they run off I'm like [ __ ] is
this I could really take your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know apparently like a lot of I
guess the crimes are abductions are
kidnappings and whatnot happen at a
grocery parking lot parking lot okay
then the parents are pretty describe no
no so so like so like let's say you're
alone right and you're like you're
putting the groceries away into the
trunk that's a lot of time in between
because like you're you're only paying
attention to putting your groceries in
the trunk you're not paying attention to
any of your surroundings and so at that
time somebody could like swipe you away
or if there's like a van parked next to
your car all right man yeah so what you
would do is you have to go to the
passenger seat and get into the driver
seat that's why I walk I told you
groceries you got to go outside the
minute open my trunk I take out my
shotgun and I'm just letting my shotgun
in the air while I'm loading my
groceries into the car and I put it away
you're so oblivious to life
you think I'm oblivious but I'm actually
not oblivious I like the bait
[ __ ] I purposely go door
so you're like I don't like my back
facing the entrance because I want to
see what's going on I personally I
purposely go like this and I show the
world my booty ball to bet your traps
are hella obvious school is way too
obvious no I remember when I was little
my mom like she would sometimes put us
in the car first and then unload the
groceries mark
hmm I mean yeah maybe but for me
personally when I have Isaac especially
when he was younger yeah he's with me
yeah always like he is never leaving my
sight handcuff him next to you every
time to go to the grocery store oh yeah
just handcuff him like this so you're
you're just together just hold his hand
you know what I could sleep cuz it's a
sweaty hot day but what if you need to
half the load so it was raining that day
well happens if you need to has the load
something what I do is I leave him in
the seat in the in the shopping cart I
leave him in there and then I'm
unloading everything while he's still
there I could see him so then I take him
with me to put the card away and then I
pick them up and I carry him back to the
car I I treat everyone like they're
about to rape me every stranger but then
because I'm socially like good with
people
I just be like hey what's up and I have
conversations but in the back of my head
I'm like you can't rape me
that's tight how's your day awesome in
the back of my head you can't rape me
nice day thank you bye YouTube you
didn't you couldn't rape me cashier are
you guys against having like the
backpack leash on your kid ah
well it depends if I have a really like
hyper kid that runs off I wouldn't be
against it cuz now I'm like [ __ ] like
I'm doing really good kids dependent off
yeah and I'm putting a chain around my
waist and putting a hit on his waist and
so when they pick him up and try to drag
him off it's just me going like this I
guess I be dragged unless I carry says
his name is gold is it chain though
they do have that like dog walker thing
where it's like it extends and but I'm
not gonna have it like where I have him
on a leash I might have it hip-to-hip it
gets rid of that weird he's not a dog
well guess what who's walking who he's
probably walking me you can't tell him
give him a choke collar yeah I remember
I remember my mom gifted me that like it
was like a little panda backpack that
was kind of like a leash and I kind of
got offended I'm like I wouldn't use
this on my child like come on I wouldn't
be running around and you haven't
implants like I was so young like what I
don't know like dumb young naive mom
right so then now I see kids I are like
that they're crazy super hyper like
parents can't even like get ahold of
them and then that's what I'm like oh
[ __ ] if my kid was like that I'm for
sure I can't judge anybody who'd use as
a because I don't know the type in a sec
he's like that Santa Claus your ass Oh
perfect I like that I don't even have
kids I want to have that for chess she's
a pretty crazy baby
[Music]
you
[Music]